jimmy  you're alive  i know i'm alive right i'm okay yeah  we're happy to say  what did you make of that moment there  dude i mean you stunned us all honestly  i didn't i made nothing of it because my  eyes closed i had no idea where i was it  was one of the weirdest things that has  ever happened to me  and celebrating quentin tonight i mean  is it not an amazing night to witness  you know what she is so unbelievably  talented and i saw her pilot before  it came out on abc and i wrote to her i  was like i don't know how we got this  but uh congratulations you you made a a  pilot that  any network would be ecstatic to get  yeah yeah and she's an inspiration with  her work ethic you know when she wins  these awards we're all like yeah give  her the awards and she's a lovely person  as well yeah  jimmy thank you thank you appreciate you  brother  you